The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
You can probably figure out,
I'm not Professor Guttag.
He's away today.
And so he's asked me to cover
this lecture, which
I'm happy to do.
I'm asked to remind you
that there is no
recitation on Friday.
I was expecting at least a
smile or a small cheer.
Early lead into spring break.
This ought to be good.
So my understanding is that
at the end of last class,
Professor Guttag was walking you
through a set of classes.
And I want to remind you
of where you were.
I want to look at one of those
classes in a bit more detail,
because we're going to
show you one new
piece of the language.
And then we're going to turn to
a different topic, which is
going to be the subject for
the next several lectures.
So just to remind you where
you were, Professor Guttag
showed you a set of classes
which started off with a
person class.
There's a definition I'll
put up on the screen.
This was just something that
created a kind of object.
I'm not going to go through the
details, but you had the
standard things you'd expect.
You had a way of initializing
it.
So you'd make each instance.
And it had a way of pulling
out the name, so you could
have a full name and
a last name.
You could get out pieces of it,
it set birthday, it had
age, it had a bunch of stuff.
And that's fine.
The second thing that he did
that we do in a lot of dealing
with classes is he created
specialization of that, a
thing called an MIT person.
And you all know that
MIT people are
special people, right?
And what did an MIT person do?
Well, again, you
can look at it.
It had, again, an init method.
But one of the things that was
a little different here-- you
may have seen it in some other
places-- is that we can
create, inside of that class
definition, an internal variable.
In this case, it was
the ID number.
So that every time we created an
instance of this class, we
could give that instance
a special number
and a unique number.
And that was exactly what
we did here, right?
If you're going to create one
of these things, you set the
ID number to be the
next number.
And then you would increment
that, so that you'd be able
to, next time you created
an instance,
give it a unique number.
And that let you do things like
put things out in order,
and things of that sort.
There was also a method in this
class that we're going to
use in a second, which is
something that would say, is
this person a student?
I'll just highlight for you
there the definition of it,
which said you'd look at the
type of the instance and say,
is it undergrad or grad?
And that was the other two
specializations we had here.
We had undergraduates and
we had graduates.
And again, I'm not going to
worry about the details.
You saw this last time.
Undergrads, they have some
methods like you could create
an instance of it -- you'd
have its year.
You could give back
what the year was.
And for the graduate students,
we didn't even bother with
putting details in.
It could be anything you want.
Now these are things that you
ought to be getting used to
looking at.
So this is creating some
class definitions.
I can make some instances.
There are a couple of nice
variations like, for the MIT
people, each one has a unique
identifier, which lets us keep
track of them.
I think where Professor Guttag
ended up last time was
actually creating
a course list.
So a list of students in
a class, like 6.00.
So I want to show you that, and
I want to show you some
highlights of that.
So there's the definition.
It's on your handout as well.
So what does a course list do?
Well, the idea should be, it's
a way of collecting together
all the students in 6.00.
So if you look at our init
function up here, when we
create an instance of a course
list, what does it do?
Well, we give it a number,
like 6.00.
And it's going to bind that
locally inside of a
definition.
And it's going to create
a collection, a list.
It's going to be a list
of all the students.
Now if I'm going to do that, I
need to have a way of putting
students into the class.
And I know nobody drops 6.00,
but just in case-- drop date's
coming up-- we have to have some
way of removing a student
from a class.
So I'm going to have a
method right here--
oops, sorry, I'm going to
get it from the right
place, right there--
that would add a student in.
Now take a look at that
for a second.
It's not just putting the
student into the list.
The very bottom down here,
that last line,
self.students.append().
What's that doing?
Well, self, remember, refers
to the instance.
.students will get me that
list for that instance.
And then .append says, add on
to the end of that list the
person that I just added
in, the person
that is bound to who.
The things above it
are being careful.
They're defensive programming.
They're ways of saying, look,
make sure that the person is
actually a student.
Huh.
Wait a minute, where'd
that come from?
isStudent.
Oh, yeah, that was up
here in MIT person.
So we're making an assumption
here that says, we're only
adding in students.
No post-docs are welcome.
We're going to only
add in students.
So we're taking instances of one
of these two classes, and
checking using the inherited
method to make sure that this
person is actually a student.
And we're doing this in a
careful way, which is we're
going to raise an error if, in
fact, it's not a student.
And then the second thing,
notice, that we're going to do
here is we're going to say, gee,
make sure that we're not
adding you twice.
So we're going to do what?
We're going to say, get
out the list of
students right there.
and I begin.
self is pointing to the
instance.students gives me the
list of students currently
in that instance.
And I'm basically saying, is
this person in that list?
And if they are, again, I'm
going to raise an error
saying, wait a minute, you're
already in the class.
So these are things I'm sure
you've seen before.
But they're ways of being a
little careful about the
programming.
The removeStudent is
roughly the same.
So let's just look at
some examples here.
I've created a set of people.
And just to show you what they
look like, let's go down here.
So I've created m1.
Let me do that again,
sorry about that.
I'm going to run this.
All right.
So if I look at m1--
it's not liking me, is it?
We'll try it one more time.
I'm going to look at m1.
It gives me back an instance
of an object.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
if I actually say a print of m1,
it'll print out the name.
And the same thing for the
undergraduates here.
So I've made a couple of
undergraduates, I've made a
couple of graduate students.
And notice what I've
done down here.
I've created a course,
SixHundred, by calling
CourseList.
So CourseList is going to make
an instance of that.
I gave it the name.
So we can go back over here.
Let's look at what
SixHundred says.
OK.
I'm sure you're used to reading
that gobbledygook.
It says, ah, it's an instance,
and it's an instance of a
CourseList.
And it gives me a pointer
to where it is.
Now what if I want to see the
students inside this course?
I'd like to see, who are
all the students there?
So printing SixHundred--
let's see if that does
the right thing.
Oops, no.
That kind of makes
sense, right?
SixHundred is just pointing
to an instance.
So where are the students?
They're sitting down inside of
an internal variable, which
is, in fact, in this case,
the list of students.
So one way I could do this is I
could say, take SixHundred,
which is an instance, and
go into that frame that
corresponds to that
and look up the
local variable, students.
And if I do that, oh,
I've got a bunch of
students named Main.
Now this shouldn't surprise
you, right?
This is doing what?
It's giving me back that
instance of the list.
If I actually want to print out
the names of the students,
I have to do something a
little more careful.
So here's one way
I could do it.
I could say, for every student
in that list, let's print out
their name.
Oh, good.
You're wondering, why
am I doing this?
Well, I want to show you what's
going on in this class.
And then I want to highlight
something for you.
So let's think about
what I just said.
I want to get the names of all
the students in the class.
So I took the instance, I went
in and pulled out an internal
variable, and then I did a for
loop that walked along it,
printing those out.
Is that a good idea?
Is that a not-so-good idea?
Is that a really bad idea?
Don't you hate professors who
ask questions at 10 o'clock in
the morning?
Well, I'm going to suggest that
it's not a great idea.
And here's why.
I'm reaching into an instance
and pulling out an internal
variable and doing something
with it.
A much cleaner way of dealing
with that is to build an
interface, to build a function,
a method, that
belongs to that instance,
that would give me back
the pieces I want.
And the reason I'd like that is
then I don't have to worry
about, if I change my mind in
terms of how I represent
things internally, all I have
to do is think about that
interface function.
Right
So the last thing I want to show
you here in this example
is let's look, in fact,
right here.
I've added a method called
allStudents.
But it's a little different,
I think, than things you've
probably seen before.
So what's the idea?
I want allStudents.
To be a function, or a method.
When I call that, I
want it to give me
back all of the students.
Now, I could have had it just
give me back the list, but I
might want to have the method
give me back not just all the
students, but maybe some
students, like only the
undergraduates in the class.
And in fact, right below
there, I've got a
method that does that.
Let's look at this one.
It says, I want to get back the
undergraduates in the class.
And what's it do?
It's going to do a
little counting.
It's going to set index to 0.
And then it's going to run
through a while loop where it
basically takes each student
and checks its type.
This is something you've seen
before, taking a loop and
walking along, taking each
element of that list and
saying, if it's an
undergraduate, I'm going to
give you back that student, and
I'm incrementing index at
the bottom.
Here's the funky thing.
I've used a word called yield.
And that's different than
you've seen before.
I'm not directly accumulating
a list.
You don't see anywhere where I'm
building up a list here.
So yield is an example of a form
that you're going to want
to use called a generator.
Now a generator is a little bit
like a return, but with
one big exception.
If I had a return in that method
somewhere, when it
found the first thing, it's
going to give me back the
value and it's done.
And so any information it stored
about where it was in
that computation--
the phrase we use is it gets
popped off the stack frame.
Yield is a little different.
And it's different because
a generator--
I'm going to write this
down carefully.
A generator is a function that
remembers the point in the
body where it was.
It remembers the point in the
function body where it last
returned, plus all the
local variables.
So what does this mean?
It says, it's going to keep
track of what was the state
when I did the computation, so
that if I call it a second
time, it goes right back to that
state and continues the
computation.
If I called it a third time,
it goes right back to that
state and gives you a
continuation on the
computation.
So in fact, what yield does,
what a generator does, is what
you would do what you normally
walk through a list.
But it gives you some control.
So it gives you a way of
actually deciding, how do I
want to create something I
could use in a for list.
And if we go back and
look at it, you can
see it right there.
The method definition for
UGs, undergraduates--
if I call it, it is basically
going to walk through, one at
a time, each element in the
underlying representation and
generate for me the next
element of the
thing I want to use.
So let me show you a couple
of examples of using it.
In this case, I've buried inside
of a for or a while
loop, but if I go over here, I
should be able to do things
like, are all the students
in SixHundred?
And notice the open/close
paren,
because that's a method.
I need to call it.
Now you're going, whoop-de-do.
That's just like the print
thing I did before.
But the difference here is I'm
controlling now how I get
access to those.
And to show you just a slightly
different way of
doing this, I could now do
things like say the following.
For all the students in
SixHundred, and I'm going to
take all the students
again in SixHundred.
So notice what I'm
doing, two loops.
And I'm going to create
something that basically keeps
track of where I am in each one
of those loops using that
yield function.
So take a look at what
it printed out.
That outer loop is using the
generator to generate each
element of the list.
It hangs onto that, so that
the inner loop can walk
through again, a generator
going through each
element of that list.
And I'm printing out
students squared --
first student times all other
students, second student times
all other students,
third student
times all other students.
And of course the other
thing I can do is I
can do the same thing--
sorry about that-- for s in
SixHundred undergrads.
And in this case, it's walking
through that internal
representation, generating each
element that satisfies
the constraints.
OK.
It's a little esoteric,
but you're going to
find it really useful.
And it's the last piece, I
think, of syntax you're going
to see for a while in terms
of the language.
You could do this by just
manipulating the list directly.
But the idea of a generator
you're going to find really
useful when you want to
control access to a
collection.
Really think of the generator as
something that keeps track
of the state of the computation,
so it can go back
and pick it up whenever
it needs it.
OK.
That wraps up that
piece of what
Professor Guttag was doing.
So I want to now switch to a
completely different topic,
which we're going to do today,
we're going to do Thursday,
and it may well carry into
after spring break.
The second topic deals with,
how do we go about building
computational models to
solve real problems.
And I want to start by putting
up here a comparison.
For much of the history of
science, people focused on
trying to find analytic
methods.
Big word, what does it mean?
Well, an analytic model is
something that lets you
precisely predict the behavior
of a system, just based on
some initial conditions and
a set of parameters.
So this is a mathematical
function, if you like.
You can predict behavior given
some initial conditions and
some parameters.
Newtonian physics, 8.01--
analytic models.
Spring constants--
They're things that let
you predict what a
system's going to do.
For, I don't know, several
centuries, this was basically
what science did.
It was really useful.
It lead to things like calculus
and to things like
probability theory.
It lead to basically
understanding the macroscopic
physical world.
So it's the stuff you
saw in high school.
That's nice.
But it doesn't always work.
And indeed, as the 20th century
progressed, one of the
things we saw was that there are
places where this doesn't
really satisfy what you need,
and you're better off with
simulation methods, which
is what we're going
to talk about here.
So what do I mean by
simulation methods?
First of all, let me talk about
why do we want to get a
simulation method.
The idea was that there are
going to be some places where
it's really hard to
build a model.
So in fact, places where
this comes up--
sometimes we have systems
that are not
mathematically tractable.
Again, a highfalutin word.
What does it mean?
It says, there are some systems
where it's really hard
to build a physical model
that exactly predicts
what's going to happen.
Think weather forecasting.
It doesn't work well.
Actually, in Boston,
it's easy.
Just assume it's going to
snow, and you're fine.
All right.
That's one reason why
we want to move
towards simulation models.
Here's a second reason why
we'd like to move towards
simulation models.
There's times when, in fact,
as things get more complex,
we're better off just
successively refining a series
of simulations.
In other words, rather than
spending the effort trying to
build a very detailed predictive
model, analytic
model, just run a simulation
that gives us an insight to
what the problem's doing.
We'll refine the simulation,
and we can keep
going on like that.
The third reason you might like
to do it is it's often
easier to extract useful
intermediate results from a
simulation than it is
to try and build a
detailed analytic model.
And of course, the last
one is pretty obvious.
The advent of computers
made this possible.
I want to just give you
an example of this.
Put yourself back in the 1700s
and think about how you would
do a computation.
You have two choices.
You can crank it out by hand.
Good luck.
Imagine how detailed
a model you could
actually do that way.
Or you could build
really precise,
detailed mechanical models.
And in fact, there are wonderful
collections of these
from people like Leonardo.
For example, people that wanted
to understand the solar
system built what were called
mechanical orreries, which
were these very complex pieces
of clockwork that allowed you
to try and predict the motions
of the planets.
That's a really expensive way
to try and do a simulation.
So computation suddenly makes
things change a lot.
Now just to give you a sense of
this, I did the following
experiment this morning,
to see how
important simulation is.
And I haven't really said
what simulation means.
So simulation means giving me
an estimate, rather than a
prediction.
Giving me a sense of what might
happen to a system under
certain conditions and doing
that multiple times, actually
running, if you like, a model
of the system rather than
trying to predict exactly
what's going to happen.
So I did the following
experiment this morning.
I went to Google--
I could have gone to Bing--
and I typed in "finance
simulation." I got 5 million
hits, most of them probably
wrong by the
way, but that's OK.
I typed in "biology
simulation." I
got 11 million hits.
I typed in "physics
simulation." I
got 15 million hits.
And then finally, I typed in
"game simulation." How many
hits do you figure I got?
North or south of 15 million?
North.
Yeah.
50 million hits.
OK, so why should you care?
A, it's fun to do.
B, it's really a common tool
that we want to use here.
So let's think about what a
simulation would look like,
and then we're going to
start building one.
So the idea of a simulation,
then, is-- what we're trying
to do is we want to
build a model with
the following property.
It's going to give useful
information about the behavior
of a system.
Boy, there's a statement that
has no content to it, right?
Let me tell you what
I mean by that.
I'm going to compare this
to an analytic model.
An analytic model would exactly
predict what this
system's going to do.
With a simulation, we want to
build a model that says, if I
give you some sense of the state
of the system, it will
give me some information
about how that
system is going to behave.
It may not be exactly right, But
it's going to give me some
simulation of it.
Another way of thinking about it
is it's going to give me an
approximation to reality.
And another way of saying it
is simulation models are
descriptive, not prescriptive.
So what does that mean?
An analytic model
is prescriptive.
You're doing 8.01 problems.
You type in the definition of
the parameters of the problem,
and it would tell you, at least
to the accuracy of the
computer, exactly what's
going to happen.
With the simulation, it says,
given a particular scenario, I
can give you a good guess of
what's going to happen.
But it might actually be the
case, by the way, that for
exactly the same scenario, I
run the simulation multiple
times and I might get slightly
different answers.
Because maybe the world, as we
said over here, is something
that we can't model exactly
mathematically.
So we want to be able to have
that ability, to sort of go
back and forth.
Now probably the easiest way to
think about this is let's
look at a model and
a simulation.
So the idea here is I want
to build simulations.
I want to control the
fact then I may not
get a precise answer.
I might not get the same
answer every time.
But if I do enough simulations
of a circumstance, I can get
some good sense which I can
refine of how this object's
actually going to behave.
So here's the example I'm
going to start with.
I'm going to go back, again,
a couple hundred years.
In 1827, a Scottish botanist
named Robert Brown observed
that a pollen particle suspended
in water seemed to
just float at random.
You've probably heard
this term.
It's called Brownian motion,
named after Robert Brown.
He had no plausible
explanation for
this, by the way.
He just observed it.
And he made no attempt to model
it mathematically, which
kind of makes sense.
That's 1827.
The first really clear
mathematical model of Brownian
motion didn't come around
until 1900.
A guy named Louis Bachelier had
a doctoral thesis called
"The Theory of Speculation."
Part of the problem for
Bachelier, though, was that he
didn't model Brownian in
pollen particles.
He did it in finance markets.
And that was considered, at
least at the time, completely
disreputable.
And so nobody paid any attention
to his thesis.
That's not going to happen
to your thesis.
Your thesis is going to be
reputable when you get done
with this place.
So it took eighty years
to get to that point.
Unfortunately for poor
Bachelier, five years later,
another person came along and
actually built the kind of
model that introduced this
sort of-- what's called
stochastic thinking into
the world of physics.
This was a model that was almost
exactly the same as
Bachelier's, but it was
used to confirm the
existence of atoms.
Anybody know who did
that model in 1905?
No physics buffs here.
If I told you he was born in
Switzerland, would that help?
A minor guy named
Albert Einstein.
So that was one of the first
things Einstein did, was he
actually built the
first really good
model of Brownian motion.
And that allowed, in fact, this
kind of thinking to go
into real-world problems.
So Brownian motion is an example
of a tool we're going
to use a lot.
I'm probably hiding that
below the screen where
you can't see it.
It's an example of what
we call a random walk.
Random walks you're going to
see all over the place.
They're an incredibly useful way
of building a simulation.
And the essential idea of a
random walk is, if I've got a
system of interacting
objects--
could be pollen particles--
I want to model what happens
in that system under the
assumption that each one of
those things is going to move
at each time step under some
random distribution.
It's going to move in a
particular direction.
I want to model what the
overall system does.
OK, let me give you some
examples of where this is
really useful.
It's really useful in modeling
physical processes.
Well, we're going to start with
pollen particles in air.
But you could think about any
kind of particle in water.
You could think about
any kind of air
particle in a larger fluid.
Ah, weather.
Modeling weather-- if we could
really model the motion of all
those molecules-- is just a
really large random walk.
Random walks are really
useful in
understanding biological processes.
For example, the kinetics of
displacement of RNA from
heteroduplexes of
DNA is a great
example of a random walk.
And in fact, people interested
in bioinformatics or
computational biology will see
random walks used all the time
to try and to understand the
displacements of things.
It's really useful in
social processes.
Movement of the stock market is
definitely a random walk,
except for the day when the
markets are all crashing for
unfortunate reasons.
So it's something we
want to use a lot.
In the example I'm going to use
to motivate a random walk,
we're going to build
a simulation.
Here is what was
the traditional
view of a random walk.
So here's the motivation.
Excuse me a second.
Let's take a drunken
university student.
Not an Institute student,
a University student.
So this is a Harvard student,
not an MIT student, because I
know you're all well-behaved.
At least smile at me when
I make these bad jokes.
Thank you.
All right.
You've got a drunken student.
They're out on a big field.
And they start off in the middle
of the field, and every
second, this student can take
one step in one of the four
cardinal directions.
So north, south, east, west.
After 1,000 seconds--
after 1,000 steps--
how far away is that student
from where he
or she started out?
So I need some help here.
Guesses.
1,000 steps.
How far away after 1,000
steps is that student--
we'll make it a he.
From where he started out.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It depends on the
probability of what direction
you're going.
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's
assume that the steps
were equally likely.
The four steps-- north, south,
east, west-- they're all
equally probable.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the suggestion over here
is, where he started.
So 0 distance away.
That's not a bad guess, right?
You're just going in different
directions.
It's equally likely you end
up where you started.
So one possibility is 0.
You end up back where
you started.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe 150 or so?
PROFESSOR: Well, I'm going
to take bets here.
I've got 150.
It's an interesting number.
Not bad.
Any other guesses.
This side of the crowd.
I don't want to just
do the right side.
I'm very liberal.
I want the left side of
the crowd over here.
Somebody over on this side.
Help me out.
Any other guesses?
I've got 0, and I've
got 150 steps.
Boy, I get no eye contact
when I do this.
This is great.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: 500 root 2 steps?
PROFESSOR: 500 root 2.
Can I drop the root
2 for second?
The 500 is not a bad
guess, right?
Because you're about half
the distance away.
The root 2 we'll come
back to in a second.
Keep that in mind.
All right.
500.
So we've got 0, we've got
150, we've got 500.
Well, gee, that's the whole
point of building the
simulation.
Let's see if we can figure out
what might happen here.
Ok.
And I'm going to build the
simulation in a second.
But before I do that, one of
the good things to do is to
try and build a simple model
that we could use to get an
intuition about what's
going to happen.
So I'm going to start with
a very simple model here.
There's my field.
The guys who mow the lawn at
Fenway have been over and very
nicely put x- and y-axes
onto this field.
And let's assume the students
starts off there.
We'll just call that
the origin.
It doesn't matter what it is,
but that's where the students
starts off.
And what I want to do is I want
to get a very rough sense
of how far away the student
might go after a few steps.
We won't be able to go very far,
but enough steps that we
can start estimating this.
So they start there.
After one step, there
are the places the
student could end up.
Equally likely.
So after one step, if I want to
build a distance associated
probability, there's probability
1 they're 1 unit
away, no matter which
direction they went.
OK, let's take this one here.
Let's assume the student
went east.
In fact, they're all going
to be roughly the same.
And the second step, where
can the student go?
He can go there, he can go
there, he can go there, or he
could go there.
Right?
So what are the distances
here?
Well, in one out of four cases,
he's at a distance 0,
which would be back to where
we started, which is that
original pretty good guess.
If he goes there or he goes
there, those are both what
distance away?
Root 2, right?
So it could be root 2 away,
2 out of 4 times.
And if we went east again,
we're 2 units away.
Again, with probability
1 in 4.
I'm cheating slightly here, in
the sense that I should do the
same things if the first step
was north, south, or west, but
they're all symmetric to this.
So it'll all come out
the same way.
So there is what happens
after two steps.
Now let's do one more step.
It's going to get a
little messy here.
But suppose I want to
go three steps.
About three possibilities.
Well, I've got three
possibilities.
If I'm in this case, which is
the 0 case, I'm here, in which
case no matter which step
I take, I'm 1 unit away.
So this will say, distance 1.
And the probability of being
here was 1/4, so the
probability again is still
1/4 that one unit away.
Let's take one of these,
the root 2 ones.
That says I'm either
here or I'm there.
They're going to be symmetric.
If I'm here, where can I go?
I've got possibilities
going to those.
So these two are 1 unit away.
So half the time I'm 1
unit away, and it was
1/2 that got me there.
Did I do that right?
Yes.
That's also with 1/4.
That was getting if I went
here or I went there.
If I'm up here or I'm over
there, that's root 5 away.
So let me put that over here.
So I've got a probability of
1/2 getting there, and a
probability of 1/2 from here
of getting that, so that's
also with probability of 1/4.
And then what's the one
case I have left?
The case I have left is I went
all the way over to here, two
steps over, in which case
I'm going to go what?
There, there, there, or there.
If I just pull these
together--
I'm just going to
do them for you.
That says, I have a probability
of being 1 away
with probability 1/16, root 5
away with probability 1/8 --
and I'm running out of room here
-- and 3 units away with
probability of 1/16.
Don't sweat the details.
What you can see is I'm
just building this up.
What I want you to see is what
do the distances look like?
After one step, I'm
one unit away.
After two steps,
that was this.
You can kind of do the
math in your head.
What's the expected
distance away?
What's the average distance
I'd be away?
Well, it's 0 times 1/4,
plus root 2 times 1/2,
plus 2 times 1/4.
So that's 1.4, that's 2.8, and
that's 4.8 divided by 4.
So it's about 1.2.
Now I'm sure you can do the math
for three steps in your
head, right?
Yeah, right.
But if I do that, if I add those
things up-- you can go
do this yourself-- what you'll
find is that this is
about 1.4 or 1.5.
Let me make it 1.4.
It's probably a little
bit closer.
All right.
Why was I doing that?
This is something you want to
do as you start building a
simulation, which is do a little
bit of a calculation to
get a sense of what you
expect to happen here.
So what conclusion could
I draw from that?
Admittedly on very small
numbers, it looks like the
more steps the Harvard student
takes, on average the further
away they are from the
starting point.
So your 0 was a great guess,
but it's probably not
going to work here.
And we want to see why.
On the other hand, 500
that looks-- well,
maybe we're still OK.
Three steps, half of 3
would be 1 and 1/2.
So maybe the 500's OK.
Let's see what happens
if we do this.
So what I want to do is see
how I could build a set of
classes that would let me
build this simulation.
And part of the design process
here is I want to try and
invent classes that correspond
to the types of things I
expect to see happening.
So in this case,
what do I have?
I need to model a drunk, I need
to model a field, which
is where the drunk's wandering
around in.
And I'll need a third thing,
which may not be obvious
immediately.
But the third thing I'm going
to need-- so let me just put
the pieces up.
I need a drunk, I need a field,
and I need to keep
track of where the drunk
is in the field.
So I'm going to pull out another
class I'm going to
call a location, that's going
to tell me where the drunk
actually is.
OK.
With that in mind, I'm going
to show you some code.
I'm going to walk through it
reasonably carefully, just to
let you see what
it looks like.
So there is my class definition
for a location.
Now at this stage in the course,
hopefully you can look
at that and already see
the main pieces of it.
So what do we have in here?
Well, we going to have
an initialization.
You can kind of see
that right there.
When I create a Location, I'm
giving it an x and y.
I'm going to make
an assumption,
which is they're floats.
I'll come back to that
in a second.
And that's just going to
store them away in
some internal variables.
That's things you've
done before.
So self.x gets that value,
self.y gets that value.
And of course, I could get out
the values right there.
I need to know where
the drunk goes.
So one of the things I'd like
to do is to say, given the
current location of the drunk,
I might like to know how far
away is that from some other
location, like the place the
drunk started.
So that last method down
here, distance from--
notice what it's going to do.
It says, if you give
me another,
which is another location--
remember, self will point
to my instance--
what can I do?
Well, I can just do Pythagoras's
theorem to figure
out how far away am I. I get
the x- and y-coordinates of
the other location.
I get my own x- and
y-coordinates.
And then I just take those
distances squared and take the
square root of them.
So it's just giving
me distance away,
which is pretty nice.
There's one other method here
which is a little funky.
This is a design choice.
And that method is the one
up here called move.
So the background to this
is going to have
a drunk at a location.
one of the things I
will want is to be
able to change location.
So move says, if you give
me a change in x
and a change in y--
I'm going to assume
they're floats--
I will give you back the new
location, which is to go from
my x and y by some amount.
It could be in the
east direction.
north direction.
But notice what it returns.
It returns a new instance
of a Location.
OK.
I made a couple of assumptions
which are worth
thinking about here.
So one assumption is
I'm assuming that
this is a 2D world.
You can't elevate.
You can't rise up.
There's no change in altitude.
That kind of makes sense.
The second assumption I made was
I said, I want to build it
in so that things like delta-x
and delta-y are floats.
What is that doing?
Well, that's saying, I don't
want to restrict myself to
just moves that are only in
the cardinal directions.
I'm going to start there, but
initially, I'd like to have
the ability that the move could
be along a diagonal, or
it could be some partial step.
So notice I'm making a choice
there that is kind of nice.
All right.
That gives me locations.
And that's a pretty
straightforward class.
So I've got locations.
That's always a good start.
I have this.
Now again, I want
to model a drunk
wandering around in a field.
So the second thing I need is I
need to say, what's a field
going to be?
And I want to show you
that definition,
which is right here.
And a field is basically going
to be something that maps
drunks to locations.
So a field is just going to
be a collection of drunks,
keeping track of
where they are.
So let's look at what that
definition says.
When I create a field, right up
here at the top it sets up
a variable inside of that
instance, just called drunks.
And we're going to
use a dictionary.
We could use other choices, but
the dictionary is going to
be nice, because it's
going to let us keep
track of the drunks.
I can add a drunk
to the field.
So notice what it says.
It says, given I've got a field,
I'm assuming I have a
drunk and a location, because
the drunk's got to be in a
particular location.
Notice what it does.
First of all, it checks to make
sure that I don't already
have this person in
my collection.
So that first check there says,
if this particular drunk
is already in my dictionary,
I complain.
You can be drunk enough to see
double, but you can't be drunk
enough to be double.
Another bad joke right
off the back wall.
Great.
OK, so what else do I want?
Otherwise, notice what
I'm going to do here.
I want to make sure
you can see these
things fairly cleanly.
If I'm going to add a
drunk, what do I do?
Into the dictionary, under that
label of drunk, I'm going
to insert a value corresponding
with that label.
And the values going
to be the location.
So my representation here is now
a dictionary of drunks and
where they are.
And that's going to be handy
as I want to use this.
And again, if I want to get out
the location, well, I just
return exactly that.
The final piece is, when I go
to move the drunk, I've got
some tests here to make sure
that I actually have a drunk.
But otherwise, I'm going to ask
the drunk to take a step
right there.
We have to say what
a drunk does.
That's going to give me back a
change in x and a change in y.
And then notice the funky
little call below here.
This says what?
The right-hand side says, I get
the dictionary of drunks.
I go in and index into it to
get out the actual drunk.
That's this first
part right here.
That gives me back what?
It gives me an instance.
So the dot says, for that
particular drunk, get its move
method, which was that
call, and have it
move by that amount.
And that returns for me then a
location which I can store
back into the list.
All right.
I made some assumptions
about Field.
They're worth pointing out.
No constraints on locations.
How big is this field?
As big as you want.
So I didn't build in a real
physical representation of the
limits of the field with every
location represented.
I just said, it's just a
collection of drunks.
So there's no limits on how
far the drunk can go.
The second assumption
I made here is I can
have multiple drunks.
And we're going to have a
simulation of that in a while.
You can imagine it's going to
be fun watching them collide
with each other.
All right.
And the third thing is, it
says nothing about the
patterns in which
the drunk moves.
So this is a design to
keep this clean.
It says nothing about
how the drunks move.
It simply says, give me
a change in x and y.
I'll change the location.
The last piece is we're going to
capture how the drunk moves
in a drunk.
And there's the definition
of the drunk.
What does that say to do?
Well, we're going to give it
a name, to start it off.
And the only method it has is
that thing that's going to do
a takeStep.
And here's where we're going to
build in the choices about
how they can move, what you
asked about earlier.
Notice what I've done there.
In this case, I've said, I'm
going to pick at random from
this set, stepChoices.
And that's where I'm building
in the idea that it's only
going to move plus or minus 1
in the x and y direction--
north, south, east, west.
I could clearly change that.
I'm also building in here that
it's equally likely, because
random picks one of those
equally likely.
I might decide to change that.
And I can certainly do that
if I want to move to other
directions.
But right now, that's where
I'm going to build it in.
OK.
So now we're ready to
try the simulation.
We've got what?
We've got location.
That's just representing
a place.
We've got fields.
That just lets us map
drunks to locations.
And then we've got the ability
to move the drunk around.
So I can now think
about making this
actually move around.
So let me show you
a quick example.
Let's create a drunk.
I'm picking the obvious
person.
I'm going to create
a location.
We'll call the origin just
the spot at 0, 0.
And I need to create a
field which I can do.
And then I'm going to
add Homer to this
field at the origin.
And now the last thing I want to
do is I want to have Homer
wander around.
I want to see how far he goes.
So I'm going to build a little
function over here-- you can
see right there-- called walk,
which takes the field, takes a
drunk in the field, and says how
many steps do I want him
to stagger around with?
And what's it going to do?
I'm going to set the start
location to be where the drunk
was initially.
It might be at the origin or
it might be somewhere else.
And then I'm just going to run
through that number of steps.
So range is just saying, take
the number of steps, just
moving the drunk.
And then I'll return
how far away he is.
So if I do that here, I can do
walk with that field, with my
drunk, Homer.
And let's take 10 steps.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
Let's try it again.
I was getting worried
there for second.
So we're getting an interesting
range of values.
So here's the last thing
I'd like to do.
Let's actually do a simulation
of this.
And I'm going to do this
reasonably quickly. simWalks
right here is simply going to
do what I just did, but
multiple times.
That is, it's going to take a
drunk, a field, some number of
steps, and it's going to run a
bunch of trials, however many
trials I want to get.
So I do what I just
did over here, and
collect those together.
And then I can just print out
some statistics about how far
away did the drunk
get as I do that.
And that's what drunk
test is going to do.
We're going to do it for 10
steps, 100 steps, 1,000
steps, and so on.
So let me simply run that.
I run drunkTest.
And we'll do it with
10 trials each.
OK.
Does that look right?
Does that look good?
You can tell this is
a trick question.
So what should you be
looking for there?
Look at it.
It says, if I take 10 steps, on
average I'm about 2 and 1/2
steps away.
If I take 100 steps, on average
I'm less than two
steps away.
1,000 steps, I'm about
two steps away.
10,000 steps, I'm about
100,000 steps, on average I'm
about two steps away.
Wait a minute.
Didn't we say that it looked
like, over on that board
there, that as I increased the
number of steps, I got a
little bit further away?
Hmm.
So I've done this
deliberately.
This suggests what?
The first key point, think about
what your simulation
should return.
What are good examples
to think about?
Because this doesn't
look right.
OK.
So here's how I could test it.
Why don't I try a simulation
on values for
which I know the answer?
So I'm going to go back in
here, and right here, I'm
going to replace this with--
we're either going to take
zero steps or one step.
Let's run that.
Oh, don't do that to me.
Oh, yes, I do have an error.
Thank you.
Get rid of it right there.
Almost out of time, so
this is perfect.
And now let's try
drunkStep again.
Wow.
If I take a random walk taking
no steps, on average I end up
2 and 1/2 units away.
I teleported.
That's pretty amazing.
And with perfect timing, we'll
figure out what's wrong with
my simulation next time.
Thanks.